today we're going to have a very
exciting lecture I hope and last week
those of you who are here we saw two
interesting games in e4 e5 and we learn
how to sometimes how and sometimes one
side makes what seem to be good
developing moves by the book but without
a planet without paying attention to the
opponent's threats you can be punished
for it right you can lose the game now
we are going to see a very exciting
attacking game full of sacrifices really
really a fun game to watch and hopefully
you'll enjoy it now the players are two
Russian players this is a very old game
from 1979 as you can see and the player
with the white pieces his name is your
fin Geller and he was a very very strong
Grandmaster and he was a big attacking
player he loved to attack the king how
many of you when you play just love to
attack the opponent's king yeah of
course everybody's hands up everybody
loves to attack the King now does it
always work or does it sometimes not
work sometimes it doesn't that's how
that happens too but here you will see
and I hope you will pick up from this
lesson two things one when you want to
attack your opponent's king you have to
be ready you have to make sure that you
have a whole army of your pieces ready
to attack and the second thing is you
have to be brave you have to say I don't
care even if I'm going to lose material
as long as I'm going to hunt the
opponent's king and I'm going to deliver
checkmate and something like this
happens today so the opening we're going
to talk about is going to be called the
Sicilian defense anybody ever played the
Sicilian defense white or black some of
you okay now we just want everybody to
sit down please we cannot have standing
because we have lots of room thank you
everybody needs to sit down so now
everybody is looking at the board and we
are starting so gala place is always
efore he likes open positions and his
opponent played c5 so we know that this
is called the Sicilian defense instead
of defending with E 5
hitting the center directly here we
attack the center indirectly from the
side so white plays one of the main main
variations Knight f3 he wants to take
over the control of the d4 square black
plays a six that's one of several
possible moves and now white plays the
main main variation with pawn to d4 so
of course black doesn't care that this
pawn is going to advance doesn't like to
see the pawn advances so he captures it
and the knight captures it so far so
good
and now he develops a minor piece from
the King side toward the center notice
that now the knight is attacking the
pawn on e5 why better do something about
it and normally white defends the
knighthood upon which is the best the
best move white would really love to
push the pawn and attack this Knight but
he cannot let's see if anybody can tell
me why without me even moving the pieces
just very very quickly if the pawn goes
here then black can win this pawn
immediately we have to look for a fork
there is a very cute fork yes tell me
that is correct can you see if the pump
pushes to here black is going to play
his Queen to a5 it's going to be a check
to the king and an attacking the pawn
and the pawn goes yes exactly so why
decides to defend but now White's to
push one white one's too pushy five if
white gets too pushy five here the black
King the black knight on f6 is going to
be a very miserable piece is going to
have to go backwards or is going to have
to go to the center and get captured and
the pawns are going to be funny
so black says now the form stops the
pawn okay very good so far we understand
everything the pawns are fighting for
the center and the knight is towards the
center the same thing is white and white
plays Bishop to e2 one of many moves
that are possible very logical move and
black also develops because he knows he
wants to castle as well white castles
black castles so far I am sure that all
of you can say hey aviv i could have
played those move myself no moves here
was like oh my god i could never do it
right everything is clear now a little
bit about the sicilian in the Sicilian
White has more
advantage in the center in the kingside
and black has more advantage on the
Queen side this is the queen side this
is the king side in the center so you'll
see that if black is going to try to
move pieces here is going to be in
trouble so it's much smarter for white
to go this way and black to try to play
here this is what's going to happen in
this game so f4 that move has to be
played you have to help the king side
and the center otherwise white is going
to have a very bad game so black plays
the move knight c6 developing another
minor piece towards the center
very good Bishop e3 a very important
move I have to tell you that in this
position it's very easy for white to
lose the game almost immediately lose
material immediately let me show you
what happened in one of my games
notice that this this diagonal is open
the g1 a7 diagonal and right now it's
not dangerous for white because it's his
move he can put his King in the corner
or like we said he can put his bishop
here and control the diagonal but I had
a game when my opponent played the very
funny move f5 he said hey I want to
attack
I have advantage in the center and the
King said I want to attack you and we
have what do we say before when we
started the lecture in order to have a
successful attack you have to have you
guys ready the army of the pieces have
to be participating just like a whole
team if you like sports
if you like let's say basketball or
soccer or football you know that if just
one person can't really do the job it's
very very rare but one person can beat
the whole other team you have to have
teamwork so anyway now white went for an
attack without being prepared and black
played the move Queen b6
oopsie we are pinning the knight on d4
not many ways to defend it very very
embarrassing position and when white
tries to defend with Bishop here all of
a sudden black plays a 5 attacking the
pin piece and oops the light has no good
square to go to anywhere tonight's going
to go to the Queen is going to take this
bishop with a check so yeah so we can
move the knight but if we don't move the
knight then this pawn that is worth how
much is going to take the knight that's
worth how much
yeah who's going to be happy from this
deal I agree so we understand that f5 is
too early and that's why he went Bishop
to e3 okay so why played oh sorry so buy
black played a6 again a very logical
move whatever we say black has more
advantage on the Queen side he wants to
hope to at some point maybe move that
pawn to b5 but not immediately
now I played the move a4 why did white
play this move white says listen in one
second black is going to play Knight the
extinct knight on d4 and then he's going
to push his pawn from b7 to b5 and he's
going to gain a lot of space on the
Kings side on the Queen side and he's
going to try to push the pawn here and
bother on Knight we don't like that so
white said hey I'm willing to spend one
temper one move to play this move and
stop all mobility of black on that side
yes the other question that's right
that's the point of this move that is
the point of this movie did it cost
white one move to play it but he thinks
it's important enough to do that okay so
black plays Bishop to d7 again black has
a very simple idea which he doesn't do
in this game but he should have and the
idea is to play Knight takes Knight here
trade the knight and then bring the
bishop to this diagonal via the square
now this is a very old game but we know
that now normally this Knight has to
move from the center to b3 prevent the
exchange and that's white best move even
though you take the night away from the
center then the bishop on d7 looks a
little funny
instead of being traded and coming here
he doesn't get to move okay
so white plays Bishop to f3 improving
the position you see that the bishop is
now controlling the diagonal and
controlling the square very logical
notice how all both players have
developed all their minor pieces what do
we call minor pieces you guys remember
knights and bishops right the knight and
the bishop the Knights and the bishops
are the minor squares and the rook and
the Queen are the major pieces right
very good
now black played Knight a5
okay a very interesting move he said hey
if this bishop moved from e2 to f3 maybe
this square can be mine
I like the square I want to jump with my
Knight to c4 that's a beautiful square
so white played the move Queen to e2
developing his queen connecting his
rooks notice that for now we have no
sacrifices no crazy moves
no big attack because both sides know
that they have to bring all of their
armies for the war they have to make it
so that they have all the pieces
participate if not all the pieces
participate it'll be very unlikely to
succeed so black plays are not a good
move I think he develops his queen and
connects his rooks and again he supports
the c-4 square with to jump with his
knight now it's time for white to make a
decision
what to do how do we start mobility
however we know that already
we we brought the Queen all the minor
pieces are developed the center is
controlled well by the white pawns and
pieces now it's time to start an attack
now the move that I'm going to show you
now might surprise some of you because
we're not used to it so much and I want
to tell you I don't want you to do it in
every one of your games in every one of
your positions we want to do it only in
certain positions like for example in
the Sicilian this is an idea that works
well take a look at the board and guys
I'd like to see your faces enough your
backs in the back
Thank You g4 wow this is a move that
deserves some explaining we push the
pawn in front of our King the ones that
usually defend our King and we use it
for an attack mainly because we see we
have so many white pieces here black is
not going to be able to attack the white
king at least not right now
but this move is going to gain space and
the idea is very simple we want to move
the pushed upon to g5 kick that
defending night away from f6 and gain
more and more space on the King side now
here black made a very bad move and I
will explain it he said Oh white is
about to go g5 and my knight will have
to go to e8 where else and I don't like
the fact that my night on e 8 is going
to disconnect my rocks and then this
route
will not have any moves I want to
activate this rook first and then I
don't mind that my knight comes to e8
but I will explain to you very shortly
why this is a bad idea I will tell you I
promise
instead it was time to play the move
Knight c4 he planned to do it he should
have done it now if white plays g5 then
the knight goes to e 8 okay white is a
little more space but black has some
threats of his own and the game would be
completely completely different instead
black played the move rook F to c8 he
wants to work on the queenside where he
has more space and he says my rook is
going to help the Queen on the semi-open
found a half-open C file so white play
the move g5 and the Black Knight had to
go to e 8 now I want to take a little
pause and I want everybody to look at
the board and tell me if you are if you
understand what I'm about to say if we
look at this board you see all the black
pieces are kind of in the center and the
Queen side do we agree yes who is left
kind of alone on the King side who can
raise his head and tell me which one of
the black pieces is left kind of by
himself on the King side yes the King
the black king is kind of by himself all
the pieces are a bit clumsy they are
kind of pointing in this direction and
the black king is yeah he has three
pawns and the bishop and the knight are
kind of next to him but you will see
that the black King is actually by
himself and that is bad news always keep
some pieces next to your king in case
you need them for defense now Geller who
is a big attacker now he says okay time
to move forward and the attack begins f5
monster move beautiful move look at
those pawns on g5 and f5
they take so much space how many of you
who were here last week remember we
talked about space some of you let me
remind it that let me talk about it to
the guys who were not here last week we
described space as follows we say that
we cut the board look at the board we
put an imaginary line right down the
middle for for white for for black and
now every
piece that is crossing that halfway mark
how crossing the line or it aims beyond
the line we give it one point so for
example this point is on the fifth rank
beyond the mark beyond the halfway line
beyond that imaginary line we give it a
point it controls this squared that's
another point it controlled the squared
that's another point that's already
three so four five six seven eight nine
10 11 12 13 14
did I miss anything I think 14 now let's
check for black oh the queen you're
right queen here and Queenie right 17
perfect answer thank you and the black
has one two three four five who has more
space by a lot yes by a lot this is the
beginning of bad news for black so black
in this position decided well he is
going to attack me so I might as well
start attacking as well finally the
night lands on the square he intended to
come to c4 but now white said you know
what I'm going to keep attacking you and
now he thought himself hmm when I look
at the black army I find that one square
is very very weak if you remember last
week we were talking about weak squares
let's see if one of you can tell me what
is the weakest square in the white army
how do we figure that out let's give you
that me give you a tiny hint you have to
look for a square that is not very well
protected that is not very easy to
defend with more pieces but the
opponent's pieces in this case white
they have chances to attack it somehow
so what square are squares right now
look really weak in the black army yes
you okay hy but I prefer something that
has some something on it like a pawn or
a piece or H 5 is weakness I agree
completely you'll see how right you are
in just about one minute yes
tell me the name of the square
I agree h7 is weak totally right what
else is we yes
f7 correct you want to say more yeah
yeah g7 but g7 notice the g7 is
protected by the king in the night and I
could also bring a bishop right so
that's probably not so much of a
weakness yes
f2 right here really how many pieces are
defending it with white one two three
four and how many black pieces can get
there no so that's not a media weakness
right we have to look and again remember
we talked about the black army we are
looking like this game from whites point
of view so look at the next move white
played everybody pay attention bishop to
h5 what a move now that is a very
serious move this move has such a strong
threat let's see if one of you is a good
tactical I can tell me what is white
threatening I know it's black to move
and you'll see the black try to defend
against it but let's pretend that black
plays some funny move like let's say
rook to b8 what is white threatening he
has a really strong threat it looks like
it's a sacrifice but it's not even a
sacrifice yes yes he wants to play
Bishop takes f7 check and let me show
you what I mean let's pretend black
plays some move on the Queen side and
then I'm going to play bishop takes f7
check and the King will have to take it
now my pawn goes pawn takes pawn double
check not only is the pawn giving check
but the rook on f1 is giving Chuck and
and it's a discovered check to correct
by the rock
notice that my knight on d4 is
protecting the pawn on e6 what a
disaster black lost two point is about
to lose the bishop so i sacrifice my
bishop tit for two pawns now you have to
move your king somewhere I'm guessing
you're going to move it here
and then I can play for example Knight
to d5 who is better in this position
why tis just all over the black pieces I
mean black is just lost so okay we know
what the threat is and now we understand
why black played the Move g6 he had to
cut off the diagonal of the bishop
against that weak f7 square and now why
it says to himself okay how do I get my
best pieces into the game and watch what
he did first of all he said hey why did
I push my pawns up to open files for my
pieces I would like my rope to f1 to
become an attacking piece so he took the
pawn and black took back he took with
the F pawn if you would have taken with
the H bond then White's next move would
have been even stronger than it is now
so black played here now black is
attacking the bishop on h5 but as some
of you remember from last week what did
I teach you if you can have a bigger
threat in your opponent you don't have
to respond to your opponent's threat if
your strut is bigger then never mind his
threat let's see if you guys can tell me
how can white come up with a threat here
that is bigger than pawn takes Bishop
does white have a move here that creates
a nice threat that will block will say
you know what I don't even want to take
that bishop anymore
use your imagination think yourself
which one of your pieces do you want to
bring into the game and how would you
like to do that yes although in the back
you have the right idea but I want to do
a little polishing on how you do it
let's improve just a tiny bit
you are right I want my Queen to come to
the air file because then if I get to
come to f7 the black King is going to be
crying but the question is why do I want
to go the Queen to f2 and not to after
eight let's see if anybody can tell you
maybe yourself can tell in the game you
went Queen f2 and Queen f2 is much
better the Queen f3 because what is
blacks only way to try to defend the f7
square the King is doing it but there's
only one more piece that can help the
knight on c4 that can come to e5 to
cover that square so if I go Queen f3
and you're going to play
i te5 you're going to gain a temper by
attacking my queen so he played queen f
- excellent an excellent understanding
the Queen has to come to the F file and
black cannot even imagine taking the
bishop let's talk about why in the game
he just said hey 95 I'm not letting you
in if you would have taken the bishop in
this position then white would have
played Queen f7 check black has only one
move here Queen takes this bishop with
the threat of rook to FA checkmate
end-of-the-world right this is just how
does the black Koon King look you're
safe or unsafe very unsafe everybody
agrees it's just the end of the world
here the rook is coming either to the
last rank or to the seventh rank and
that's going to be a huge attack so now
okay so he couldn't take the bishop
instead he plays Knight to e5 and now
again we are attacking and we have to
think what to do now this knight on e5
is so annoying we really don't like it
we really don't like the denied is
stopping our Queen from coming in
because in order to win we have to get
our pieces close to the black King so
again why it said you know what I know
you're attacking my bishop but I don't
feel like moving it if I move it then
maybe you're going to start defending so
we think to ourselves how do we get rid
of this knight on e5 if I was getting
rid of the knight then I wouldn't even
have to bother moving my bishop who
could tell me who can have a good
tactical eye and tell me what do I need
to do is right to start removing this
monster from afar we don't like this
Knight how do we get rid of it which one
of our pieces can we use to get rid of
the knight yes show me tell me the move
very clever
Bishop to f4 that's one way to get rid
of the knight I like it but look Geller
said to himself I might need this Bishop
later and boy is he going to use the
bishop you guys are going to wow at how
this Bishop becomes strong you're going
to really love how destroy how strong
this Bishop becomes so do I have another
piece is there another way for me
one of our pieces to get rid of this
night yes sorry yes this night right
watch Knight f3 exactly night after we
what a beautiful little move I want to
get rid of this Knight and if I get rid
of this Knight then my queen is going to
get f7 so watch what happened now now
the game gets really super exciting and
soon you're going to say oh my God look
what Geller did to his opponent so black
played the move Knight g7 and here is
his idea his idea was what happened in
the game white took the knight and now
he played what we call in chess an
in-between move yeah he want to capture
back into the night or the bishop he
can't afford to do it right now because
we know that my queen is about to come
so he played rook f8 this is called an
in-between move he says okay I'm
attacking you Queen and I'm going to
have time to take one of the attack
pieces of course Geller saw that and
watch what he prepared you guys are
going to really love what's about to
happen
first of all Geller saved his knight and
block the attack on the Queen
notice that the route can take it I have
too many defenders on it right here so
black said okay I'm going to take the
bishop and now we look at the position
we say wow black did such a good job
defending his position we have to admit
he managed to bring the rook that went
there remember how the rook move we said
it wasn't a good move he managed to
bring it back to the defense and he
managed to bring this knight to capture
our Bishop but now comes a move that is
just fantastic
hands down wait a minute I want
everybody first to look at the position
because that move is really tricky you
think yourself what what does this move
have to do with the game and why are we
giving away material well there is a
good reason it's because this is what we
call imagination in chess Geller has so
much imagination he just looks at the
King and he says I'm gonna make you dude
and that's what's going to happen so
anybody want to guess the move I mean
this is kind of hard I mean some of you
might say check and it's not a terrible
move but he wants to prepare the check
is going to come shortly and the
blocking is going to be a bit
embarrassed but white first plays
monster little move we'll see why I know
it's tough but this is why we're looking
at it so we can learn from it what do
you think f6 you would want now we're
not going to give away the Queen there's
a bishop here and there's a night here
right I would love if I could have
played Queen f6 I would have done it I
promise you but black is controlling
that Square too many times yes
for well you have you're getting there
you understand that when the black king
is going to be on this diagonal that's
why we needed our Bishop we want to put
the bishop on the a1 h8 diagonal and he
is going to embarrass the King but if I
go Bishop to d4
he might push at some point this pawn
right he is gonna block me and I don't
want him to block me I want this
diagonal to be open so I'm thinking to
myself you know I'm willing to pay any
price I'm willing to give you something
just so I can keep that diagonal open
everything for the checkmate everything
for the attack ABI you look like you're
dying to say the move and you're going
to get a heart attack if you don't so
say it Knight to d5 I knew you had it
everybody look and I will explain Knight
to d5 what a shot
now I'm attacking the Queen and I'm also
attacking this bishop with Jack and the
Queen can't even defend a bishop you
can't go here because of my knight so
you have to take the knight or else
you're going to lose a ton of material
and he did and this is the point by
forcing him to move the pawn to here he
will no longer have that point to block
the bishop and now watch what the Geller
does Knight to h6 jack and the King goes
to g7 he has to go to g7 to at least try
to get in touch with the night if he
goes to h8 Bishop to d4 is going to be
just too much
so he plays King to g7 and now the idea
is if white goes immediately Bishop d4
jack then maybe he's going to block with
the knight or the bishop on f6 and if
you take it with a pawn then my king
will take this Knight not exactly pretty
but black is going to defend instead I
want everybody to look because now comes
one of the nicest moves I've ever seen
on the chessboard white again knows no
tower building please thank you
everybody looking to the bed the board
guys drumroll this is going to be a
fantastic move everybody pay attention
the drum hold was just virtual not
really one so everybody look no real
drum rolls guys look at the board and
white played a soo
/ strong move re again you think you
know the move but I have to let other
people say - what do you think what
Square is that and let the rook take it
you say no but some people you say yes
say let's say yes as well say yes he's
going to do it look what he does Queen
f7 check yes exactly exactly
when I saw the game I also asked what
but this is working this is wonderful
watch what happens now everything for
checkmate we are willing to give any
pizzas we have to but we're not
sacrificing them crazily we have a plan
so well you've got to take and now rook
takes and the poor King has to go to the
corner the only legal move and now we
understand the idea behind that crazy
move Knight d5 why did we give who's
going to know calling the move I want to
see only hands up anybody knows what
white will play here yes what do you
think first row with what piece correct
Bishop to d4 what a beautiful attack
against the King everything is just all
the white pieces are just attacking the
King well I don't have that many good
moves here if I go Knight g7 the bishop
is going to take it and that's going to
be checkmate so I better put something
on f6 and that's what he did and now for
a moment you say wait a minute
when I count the material I see that
black is up a ton how much material is
black up who could tell me no I want an
exact count he is up a queen on a bishop
against a rock right no I'm not even
counting pawns but like the Knights are
the same the specials are the same and
this looks are the same white as a rook
and black has a queen and a bishop so
black is up a ton of material so you say
wait a minute if I just play let's say
if I play Bishop takes Bishop then the
knight is going to take and there's no
mate and you down a lot of material no
good if I play pawn takes then also
nothing but watch what Geller does
Geller plays rook takes f6 and what is
the point if Knight takes f6 Bishop they
exist is mate the knight and the bishop
are mating the poor black king how
beautiful so in this position what can
you do of course black resign he had to
resign but let's do one more exercise
what would have happened if Knight g7
wait we're not done with this game yet
what happened if Knight g7 who could
tell me what did Geller planned he had a
very good plan against Nigeria what it
may be yes
no we can't go to f8 yet because there's
a rookie right so what do we do look at
this bishop and the long diagonal and
look at this Knight feeling a little
unhappy how do we work all our pieces to
do that Adi tell me
rook f7 watch this guy's
rook to f7 my threat is Bishop takes g7
checkmate let's pretend I go rook g8
Bishop takes g7 check the rook mistake
rook the FA check the rook must go back
and rook takes rook is what do we think
about this game by Geller a monster game
huh this is how we attack the King this
is how to conduct an attack that's a
beautiful way to conduct an attack
against the king well yeah the final
position the material is just about
equal that is fair to say I agree ok
guys now I hope you guys understood the
game first of all we have more stuff to
do let's not we're not done yet
but I hope you understood what happened
in this game both sides built a good
position to control of the center castle
with their King made sure that all their
minor pieces were developed but then
when black wasn't fast enough on the
Queen side white started attacking
furiously on the King side we saw that
the worst part that happened to black
was the moment that his King was left
alone around this stage
this was right here ruk fc8
and after g5 and f5 the black king
became a bit unsafe by himself if the
rook was still here on f8 then Bishop h5
trying to attack f7 would not have been
possible yeah and then of course it will
be much harder for white to win there
will be a whole different game okay guys
now we're going to see another position
and again the theme of this position is
going to be about King safety this is
our exercise and after this exercise I'm
going to show you a problem and the
problem has a story and this is going to
be one of the nicest things you've ever
seen you know I always like to finish my
class with a beautiful little position
let's take a look at this position and
try to find out what to do we are
watching this position and what do we
see we look at the position we see King
safety the white King looks completely
safe he is behind his pawns he is well
sheltered black doesn't even have a
check we look at the blocking and we see
he might be under a little trouble the
queen is very aggressive the white queen
and the knight is very aggressive and
plus there's a rook on the foul and a
bishop but then what we count the
material we say that black is not up
anything right he's not winning on
anything so this is he's not like he is
just winning and white has to hurry but
white says to himself right now the rook
and the bishop are not developed my
pieces are all attacking and it's time
for me to see do I have something to do
about it before blacks complete this
development before black is saving the
game do we have anything in this
position do we have anything to help
continued you attack notice that right
now it looks like everything is
protected the Queen cannot take on eight
seven guys because the knight is on it
the Queen cannot take on f7 because the
Queen is on that pawn so it looks like
everything is defended black really
wants to play the move Bishop e6 for
example then is going to develop the
bishop and then is going to bring the
rook into the game if that happens I
think that black is going to be okay
so I'm going to give you about one
minute to look at the position use your
imagination you can't move the pizzas
obviously you just have to do it in your
mind and think yourself what would you
play here if you were white all hands
down I said one minute
not everybody so fast I know when I saw
this position at first I had to think
about it just a tiny bit and try to say
okay what is weak in the black army and
how can we take advantage of it in the
best possible way
okay yes I would love to do that but
what about the night on f8 is going to
take me right no follow up yes in the
blue shirt I have to tell you I like
this move that looks like a very clever
move you say hey my bishop is not
participating is going to attack the f7
pawn maybe I'm going to get it but I
think if you play Bishop 28 can I play
Bishop to e6 and defend my stuff and my
rook is attacking this Bishop as well so
again a good move but not quite enough
right Black is defending like a lion
here he's not he doesn't he refused to
lose who else
yes and other ideas to play Bishop c4
again piling up against the weakness on
f7 I see that all of you agreed that the
f7 pawn is not not a great pawn for
black but one more time I might play the
move Bishop to e6 cutting off the
control of that Bishop so Bishop c4
Bishop to e6 black is really really
trying to defend his best so what should
we do again I want everybody to take a
look hence download it just for one
second because I see that you're the
only one who is ready for with an answer
use your imagination kids I remember
what we saw what did Geller teach us
today he taught us if we see a checkmate
if we see an attack that the opponent
cannot save then we can afford to be
brave about it we can use our feet our
pieces are forces smartly and we can
punish the opponent how to do that yes
again I would love to take on 87 but
when the knight takes me then what and
then the King takes yes but then my
black King is going to take the Queen
look at this if the knight takes here
then my knight will take and if the
Queen will take then the King takes
because the Queen is not protected and
who is winning yeah we don't want to
lose right okay all the way in the back
Wow what is this move rook to d7 my
knight can take it and my bishop can
take it and my queen can take it and you
play rook d7 say yes that's right let's
see this move very good move look at
these guys
rook - dese Evan let's try to understand
why are we putting the rook when three
different pieces can take it well of
course the Queen can't really take it
because there's a bishop defending it if
you take it you're just going to lose a
lot of material and then of course
there'll be no Queen to defend here and
we already know if the knight takes it
then this is going to be a lot of
trouble right but even worse this is
going to be trouble so Wow and what if I
take with the best shop what if I go
Bishop takes rook what was the point of
this move no I want the kid in the back
because he's the one who answered tell
me very good now we saw what happened we
put something between the Queen and the
f7 pawn so by interrupting the Queen's
reception to the f7 pawn
it's called interference right right
it's like you know how sometimes we
watch television we see no signal
because there's an interference the same
thing here we just cut the signal
between the Queen and the f7 pawn the
bishop took now our Queen took well the
King has one move that's easy and now
how do we continue the attack who can
tell me I mean the Queen it's not just
made yet but the attack is going to be
just too strong how do we attack let's
hear from you yes correct
Bishop c4 I want to play Queen to GA
checkmate I better move this Knight or
else it's going to be checkmate so he
moves Knight to g6 and now oh well we
look at the position we think wait a
minute black is defending everything we
lost our rook and somehow black is just
controlling the mate but now again White
has a
beautiful little surprise I wonder if
one of you can see it I wonder if one of
you can tell me is it really over did
Wieck make a mistake and lost his rook
or does he have a move which completely
spoils the day for black let's hear from
Adie even though the rook is there all
right look at this
Queen to GA Chuck you have to take and
then smarten a knight of seven checkmate
beautiful little concept if you guys
have seen before then great if not I
want you to pay close attention up what
happened here
the queen is giving itself up to take
the last escape square from the king can
the king take the Queen no there's a
bishop do I have a legal move with my
king can I escape somewhere how about
out of the board somewhere this way now
I can do that
all right so rook mistake and then the
knight gives the the checkmate the
knight cannot be captured
we cannot block a check from a knight we
already know that and the poor King has
no legal moves his own pieces are in his
way
that's why we call it's one made because
the pieces are smothering the King yeah
the king is mother beautiful so very
quickly from the beginning to understand
what happened we gave up the rook to
take control of the f7 weakness when the
opponent took it we play check and we
played Bishop here and we know that now
Queen g8 is coming next first either is
checkmate or as yeah you could play 96
of course but then of course I'm just
taking it and now block is again in deep
mud because I'm threatening mate and my
knight distracting the Queen and if you
take it then the Queen goes bye-bye
that's right all right now one last
position for the day you guys were
really great and I think you're going to
enjoy it
now there is a small story behind this
problem this is the position and it's a
composition this is not from a real game
somebody just built this position and
say ok there's certain requirement now
there was a grandmaster who gave it to a
lot of world champions to solve and they
couldn't do it they just couldn't solve
it they struggled and struggle and
couldn't solve it just one world champ
him his name is Michael Tao I don't know
if you ever heard of him he's a world
champion was a world champion
he was a great tactician he was a big he
loved to sacrifice pieces and to attack
and he for one hour he was wondering
about this position without a board he
was just like taking a walk and thinking
about the position in his mind and then
he solved it and I'm going to show you
what the solution is when you look at
the position you think that's not
interesting white is down a piece and
those two pawns they look like they are
about to Queen like maybe you can play
something like pawn push and then the
other point is going to Queen and the
worst part is if white makes a queen or
zone then Knight f7 is going to be a a
fork check and forking the Queen so so
this looks yeah you can promote to a
knight and that is going to be kind of
even material right it's going to be
very hard to win you agree yeah Black
has more pawns even but believe it or
not this position is white to move and
win now let's be fair if the world
champions couldn't solve it it's going
to be a little hard for the class as
well right no I think so I think so but
I am going to show it to you and I think
you guys are going to enjoy it so let's
pay attention to what why did white
again this is going to what is this
going to teach you it's going to be very
hard to do something like this in your
own game because this is like a big
example but what I hope it's going to
teach you is how to use your imagination
and be creative even when the position
looks like it's a bad position like it's
not so fun you are going to use your
imagination and you're going to really
find something and this is look what
white found so white played Knight f6
Jack and okay now the black King doesn't
have many good squares because if the
black King goes to the last rank like
let's say here then the pawn is going to
Queen with Jack yeah then white is going
to win easily he's going to have an
extra queen and so he plays here to
attack the knight you cannot play King
here if you play King here then I'm
going to play Bishop h5 check and then
most that I take care of that square
then I can make a queen and
you will not have unite fork so I'm
going to make a queen I'm going to have
an extra queen that's no good okay so we
understand black has to go to g7 now the
night gave a check on h5 such a tricky
guy so you cannot go to the last rank
because I'm going to make a queen agreed
and I'm winning so he went up and then
look what why did he plays Bishop to see
to check and some of you might say Aviv
not only are you down apiece you're
about to lose you Knight why are you
giving you night again imagination look
at what white wants to do King takes
Knight now why did another roof that
seemed like it's crazy but it has a good
logic Queen and you say wait a minute
didn't you tell us that black is going
to have a fork okay so he Forks and the
black King doesn't even bother to
protect his Queen and then check King f5
now maybe some of you might have a
little imagination of what happened here
we gave up a piece we gave up as well
are very strong pawn passport but the
black king is feeling a little unsafe he
has no moves and he might get made it
can everybody see that the threat is
Bishop to d1 checkmate oh yeah
all of a sudden wait a minute let's take
a look so now all of a sudden we
understand white wasn't just crazy he
gave up his knight and he gave up his
past pawn in order to put the King in a
box in a mating we call it in chess we
call it the mating net like the kind of
net that you fish mate and now the king
is stuck
what is the only move on the board now
to prevent checkmate Adie you have to
play E - yeah
e - the only move so now watch how the
bishop is going to drive the black
pieces crazy now he goes Bishop to e4 my
idea is to play Bishop - here checkmate
Bishop f3 what is the only move on the
board to stop Bishop f3 checkmate
wait not ever somebody else yes
all the way in the back say it correct
you may have to make a night you must
stop my checkmate okay so now the bishop
went to here and now the bishop is
saying you know what all I want to do is
I want to come here and then I'm going
to come here and I'm going to checkmate
you and your Knights are too clumsy to
do anything so black has only one way to
try to stop that annoying checkmate he
has to push his pawn and when the bishop
comes here he has to make a knight he
has to stop this bishop into checkmate
but now white continues the bishops is
starting is continuing to be a super
annoying piece Bishop to b5 now I want
to go Bishop EA checkmate so the Black
Knight has to stop it and now white
plays the very annoying move Bishop a4
and there is no way to stop Bishop to D
1 followed by checkmate white wins the
game you can block with one night you
can block with the other night but I'm
just going to take everything on the
diagonal and it's going to be a
checkmate so watch how bishops that's
why we say that bishops are stronger
than nights when there's an open board
look how clumsy those Knights are
therefore Knights against one Bishop I'm
not even counting this Bishop four
Knights and they're all so clumsy they
cannot stop the move Bishop to d1
checkmate you could play something like
let's say here and I'll play here and
you can play here and I play here and
you can play any move you feel like and
I'm going to take the knight and it's
going to be checkmate correct very good
guys we are done for today you have time
for one game so I want everybody to pair
up and play one at least one game but we
have to play it quickly because we don't
have more than about 10 or 11 minutes